[Music]
good evening and welcome to tucker
carlson tonight we're nearing 200
interviews believe it or not for tucker
carlson today we're on fox nation these
are extended and very wide-ranging
interviews with people who never have
time to sit down on a regular nightly
show here on fox that includes some of
the most prominent entertainers authors
thinkers and generally interesting
entertaining people of our time you may
have seen a couple of minutes these
interviews because we broadcast them at
night sometimes but on this show this
evening we're focusing on just two
people the first is football legend
brett favre and the second is hollywood
actor john voight and we're bringing you
two extended portions right now so you
can get a sense
of what our fox nation show is all about
here is part one of our conversation
with brett favre
[Music]
who is your dad what was he like
well as i explained to him to you last
night if if you're familiar with gomer
pyle
and our generation or older certainly is
familiar with gomer pyle
sergeant carter
who yelled had a flat top
was constantly everything he said was
yelling
even when he was polite and speaking
softly
that was my dad
he was he was my baseball coach he
coached american legion baseball for 35
40 years
and he he coached high school football
for about 35 years and so me and my two
brothers
we grew up playing
being coached by even when he was not
officially our coach
there was we were
there was a lot of hard work a lot of
um
spankings
yellings
but that was that was the way we grew up
you know uh
my dad like i said he was coaching high
school football since i was a little kid
so when you screwed up he didn't make
excuses for you
he never felt sorry for me
no no
uh i i was probably treated the worst
on the whole team
and
and i
you know strangely i got that i didn't
particularly like it but i got it
you know uh
the things that he said to me and i
think sometimes don't get me wrong
and i i think i told you the story last
night had had he and i been riding back
from a practice home one one evening
and my dad's driving right here we had a
little
little small pickup truck
and had he looked over to me and said
son
how you doing in school
everything you and deanna okay
i would have
i would have thought that he had lost
his mind
that was just not his nature
um
when i did
in another example so
while i'm in green bay especially
three or four years in when i really was
playing
exceptionally well
he would he would come to games and
after the game he he'd ride to the game
with me in my truck and he would ride
back home
after the game with me in a truck and he
would critique the way i played
now
my dad was
he was not really a
a
technician
from a coach's perspective
it was more just
work hard
be tough
be a great teammate that was kind of his
three three things it wasn't like all
right we're gonna scheme him to death
he was not a schemer
he he was just
we ran the football and and i'm going
way back to where the younger generation
doesn't even know what the wishbone is
you know wishbone was was prolific back
when barry switzer and
osborne were were doing it back in there
for those who don't know what is the
wishbone
it's a quarterback's under center you
have a full back you have a half back
and a half back and you run misdirection
options
i would say if you had 70 plays in a
game
68 of them are runs
some some type of
beer option you know i don't even know
how to explain it yeah but
that's what we ran
so
i say that because when my dad would
critique me that's
for example i maybe i was 28 for 32 in
the game which is great
300 yards two touchdowns
maybe an interception maybe no
interceptions
dad would get in the truck
and rather than say well i'm proud of
you did really a good job he would say
you know
you could have completed those other
four passes
and i would say dad
don't even
think about trying to critique me for a
man who wouldn't throw a pass
or allow his son to throw a pass you're
going to tell me how
i should throw or what i should have
done better
and he'd get all been out of shape but
yeah you know
i thought i had a fair argument
so you had to be able to take criticism
yeah
yeah um
certainly from him is where it started
so like
i've had some great coaches after him
and the really good coaches
will get on your ass a little bit yeah
no matter who you are
and that's okay did i particularly like
it no but i understood that that was
part of the process and needed to be
done
and i've even had coaches say look now
i'm gonna chew your ass a little bit but
i want the other guys to know
that
you're you're no different than anybody
else on the team and i i i'm all in on
that that's fine
and but that started with my dad you
told me a story last night about being a
kid riding your bike with your brother
would you would you mind repeating that
story so
my wife loves this story
so me and my brother my older brother
scott were two years apart i'm guessing
we were probably he was 12 say i'm 9 or
10.
so
we lived on a half a mile dirt road one
way in one way out no neighbors anywhere
remotely close
several miles away
so for whatever reason we didn't ride
bikes a lot but this one particular day
we were riding down the gravel road
and i got my
if you rode bites as a kid you probably
got your pants laid caught in a chain at
some point
so i got my pants leg caught in the
chain and it kind of wrapped up pretty
good and so we're we're trying to get it
out
me and my brother scott so my dad comes
driving down the road from home
going out
you could hear the truck coming that you
see the dust
and he stops and i and i was telling you
and telling you the truth
the passenger window
there was no passenger window and the
door was held shut or somewhat shut with
an extension cord
so
he pulls up
he looks out the window and he says what
are y'all doing
so
riding bikes my pants lady got caught in
the chain we helped me get get it out oh
hell i ain't got time for that
so he takes off
he gets about 50 to 100 yards down the
road and i i do that
and all of a sudden brake lights you see
brake lights and you see the truck
stopping gravel's flying and he
hits in reverse and starts coming back
and my brother scott says you better run
well keep in mind i got my pants leg
caught in the chain and i'm not running
anywhere so i'm trying to hop into the
woods
needless to say
it was the last time i flipped anyone
off for a long time but and this is the
god's honest truth i told my dad
that i only did that because i saw
people do it when they were mad
at other people
he didn't buy it
like you didn't even know what it meant
i didn't know what he meant i just knew
that people did it when they were pissed
so
it was quite a bit longer before i ever
did that again but that was yeah that
was my dad
he was uh you know again if he was
it was very little compassion
and
if my dad would have said to me son i
love you i would have thought dad are
you okay you got fever
but i knew he loved me in his weird sort
of way
when he died famously suddenly
you played one of the best games of your
life the next day
i would say it was the best game
uh statistically speaking i don't think
anyone can argue just
the first half long you know i
when i left the game after 20 years
and i don't say this braggingly
um
i had every passing record good and bad
that you could possibly own now a since
they've all been passed
but
i i say that only because
only once in my career i think once
maybe twice did i throw for 400 yards
ever
now guys do it all the time
now at one time i had the yardage
passing record but i but
was it wasn't because i was throwing for
four and 500 yards a game at halftime of
this game
i had 399 yards
guys do it all the time now but for me
in the way my i played
that was
nothing short of a miracle
and four touchdowns
at the end of the first half so i could
have ended the game right there with
better statistics than i'd had
in any other full game in my career the
day after your father the day after
how did you do that
well
it was the hardest thing that i have
ever had to do
there was a lot of talk
prior to the game on whether whether or
not i would play speculation
meanwhile at the hotel in oakland i knew
i was going to play
because that's what my dad would have
wanted me to do and and the people who
knew uh my dad and the way that he
carried himself
all understood like
you better play in that game i mean i
could just hear him
don't you set out for this
the hard part to me was not
not playing in the game but playing well
enough to honor my father in my mind
and that was exceptionally hard um
because it was hard to focus on the job
at hand
it was a second to the last regular
season game we had to win the game
to continue our playoff
possibilities
we had to win that game and quite
frankly win the next game and hope for a
loss by another team to get in so we
needed to win
and i knew that
my teammates were counting on me
but i kind of lost track of the game
plan
for obvious reasons so i
there was a lot going on in in the least
of which was
scheming and game plan issues
so
the pressure to perform that i had
placed upon myself
was like and i played in two super bowls
played in pro bowls played in a lot of
big games but the pressure to perform at
the level that i ended up performing at
was almost
unreachable
but yet it happens
subscribe to the fox news youtube
channel to catch our nightly opens
stories that are changing the world and
changing your life from tucker carlson
tonight